صورة لم تُعرض من قبل تصور
الشدة والدراما أثناء الغارة التي
قتلت أسامة بن لادن ثم الرئيس
أوباما ونائب الرئيس بايدن في
غرفة العمليات بالبيت الأبيض، توتر
واضح على وجوههم وهم يضغطون على
وزير الدفاع بوب جيتس، إحدى
الصور العديدة المنشورة حديثًا من  داخل
البيت الأبيض في ذلك اليوم المهم في الأول من مايو
2011. سيبدو شكلهم جديدًا إذا
سارت الأمور على نحو خاطئ، وتحارب
القاعدة العمليات الخاصة، ويتم
القبض على الأشخاص أو قتلهم بن لادن،
أليس هناك تدخل الجيش الباكستاني في
الكثير من الأشياء التي يمكن أن تحدث
خطأ في هذه الصور التي حصلت عليها صحيفة
واشنطن بوست للتو من
مكتبة أوباما الرئاسية بناءً على
طلب قانون حرية المعلومات سابقًا، كانت هذه هي
الصورة التي عرفها الجمهور أكثر من
ذلك اليوم أوباما مع بايدن ثم
وزيرة الخارجية هيلاري كلينتون
وغيرهم من كبار المساعدين وهم يشاهدون سلة المهملات
غارة محملة في الوقت الحقيقي تضع كلينتون على
فمها يعتقد محلل الأمن القومي في CNN،
بيتر بيرغن، أن هذا كان في
الوقت الذي اصطدمت فيه طائرة هليكوبتر تابعة لقوات البحرية
بجدار وتضررت أثناء
الهبوط الشديد، وأجرى بيرغن مقابلة مع الرئيس
أوباما وجميع اللاعبين الرئيسيين في
الغرفة لشبكة CNN.  الفيلم الوثائقي الذي حصلنا عليه
هنا حيث لاحظنا على سبيل المثال
أن إحدى المروحيات تضررت
أثناء الهبوط وماذا كنت تعتقد أنني كنت
أفكر أن هذه ليست
بداية مثالية
أعني أن قلبك كان في حلقك طوال
الوقت الذي كنت فيه  هناك لم
أقضي أكثر من 30 دقيقة مرهقة
في حياتي من قبل، حيث تظهر الصور التي تم إصدارها حديثًا
أوباما وهو يراقب باهتمام وهو يطرح
الأسئلة عندما وردت أنباء عن
نجاح الغارة. تم تصوير أوباما وهو
يصافح جيتس، في صور أخرى
تظهر الرئيس وهو يجري مكالمات
لإعطاء المساعدة.  أخبار للرئيسين السابقين
جورج دبليو بوش وبيل كلينتون ومكالمات
لزعماء العالم الآخرين تظهر صور أخرى
الرئيس وفريقه يعملون على
الخطاب الذي سيلقيه للأمة في وقت
متأخر من تلك الليلة حيث كان بإمكانهم سماع
حشد من الناس يتجمعون خارج البيت الأبيض
في وقت واحد  من بين الصور التي تم إصدارها حديثًا،
أظهر بايدن ثم رئيس الأركان المشترك الأدميرال مايك مولن لمصور البيت الأبيض
بيت سوزا حبات المسبحة التي
لفوها حول أصابعهم
أثناء الغارة على بن لادن، ما هو المعنى الذي
أعطوك إياه من الراحة
بعد ذلك
؟  أخبرك بما قاله الكثير من الناس أنهم
قالوا إنهم أدركوا
حقيقة الأمر فقط عندما غادروا
البيت الأبيض فجأة سمعوا هذه
الكراسي وذلك عندما
قال الناس أنك تعرف أنني قال بعض الناس إنني
بدأت في البكاء،
شكرًا لك أيها
الأجنبي